the american people have to be ready for
even higher energy prices i think you
know there's an understanding of that
this is in essence a small price to pay
guys you just have to pay more for our
inept administration you just have to
pay more you just have to pay eight
dollars for gas we don't know how for
how long you're gonna have to pay more
but you do it's the price for freedom
look this is not to defend russia's
actions you cannot invade a sovereign
nation just because you want to putin
has the idea of greater russia right he
wants to return to 50 years ago and the
soviet union and all those things this
in no way is a defense of putin or his
actions but it is our own
administration's ineptitude that has led
to all of these gas prices and now they
are trying to collapse our economy so
they can usher in their green energy and
their electric cars and all of those
things and they have pumped so much
imaginary money into the economy that we
know inflation is crazy it's 7.5 percent
uh but now people are saying it could
really be as high as 10 that's that's
what's coming out today that when
they're telling you 7.5 there's actually
a lot of indicators that show that it's
closer to 10 which means you have 10
however much money you think you have in
your bank account right now go look at
your chase account you have 10 less you
have 10 less right now as the cost of
things continue to rise right so we all
know meat's going up chickens going up
all goods and services all going up on
top of the fact that the supply chain
stuff the stores don't have as much
stuff your money is worth less and the
price of things is going higher but
don't worry guys don't worry guys joe
biden's on it because you know none of
this could possibly be his fault
make no mistake
the current spike in gas prices is
largely the fault of vladimir putin
it has nothing to do with the american
rescue plan
liar liar your dementia pants are on
fire
it has nothing to do with the american
rescue plan it has nothing to do with
the fact that we just print money more
and more money and we just put it into
the economy and it just sort of sits
there and exists and people don't go to
work and nothing's really working it has
nothing to do with that when you print
money you deflate the value of money in
the first place
they are trying to destroy the dollar
and i honestly think they're trying to
destroy america i really do at this
point they are trying to destroy the
america we all know
and we all knew
that's what they're trying to do and
they lie to us about absolutely
everything so they when they lie to you
about gender
and then you accept it well then next
thing you know they're lying to you
about bio labs whether they existed or
not and then they're lying to you about
what inflation actually is and what
happens when you endlessly print money
money that we don't have in the first
place it's not like we got a whole bunch
of money just sitting somewhere and
occasionally we're going in and taking
it right like we've got this nest egg
somewhere of all this money that we've
done that we've done gone saved right
and every now and again we're like ah we
do need more because you know times are
struggling right now there is this war
like let's go into the reserves and pull
out some money we're just borrowing more
and more money and deflating the value
of american currency that's what we are
doing right now but you know thank you
joe it's not your fault it's because of
russia it's because of russia right it
has nothing to do with you canceling the
keystone xl pipeline which would have
brought 800 000 barrels of oil from
canada which now is some of it's coming
uh via railroad but it's like there were
10 000 jobs that were lost because of
this thing we could have more oil
flowing we all know this we can unleash
america's resources we've got a lot of
oil here but no no no no because they're
telling you actually we're trying to
rejigger the entire economy actually
we're trying to make sure we go to
electric uh cars and all of these things
that's what i think pete buddha judge
gay pete said we're gonna have 500 000
electric
car charging stations make it easier to
drive electric vehicles you're talking
about charging stations we're putting
together a network of 500 000 charging
stations around the country
i don't know if we can have that many
cars because we can't build anything we
can't get microchips from taiwan but
that's a whole other thing